G: okay, great, OKAY
G: Hi, Guys welcome to this YouTube channel
G: This is exciting business! I'm here with these dummies
M: Woo!
H: Hello!
G Mamrie and Hannah! And the three of us dummies are in a delightful dumb movie called "Dirty 30"
G: Comes out September 23
G: But you can pre-order now on itunes or you can go to dirty30movie.com and pre-order and get bundles with all kinds of
G: Merch associated with the film. It's real fun
M: Check it out!
H: Anybody watching who doesn't know what dirty 30 is about
H: It's about a woman's 30th birthday where her two best friends throw her a party that goes terribly right?
M: I'm the old one!
G: You guys might remember this challenge from a few years back. It's the fart sound board challenge
G: Variety Show
H: I'm intrigued
G: Here it goes. See what happens.
M: That's showbizz!
H: That's how Mamrie's farts sound.
M: Like like an asthmatic owl
G: In honor of dirty 30 and it being about birthdays which are traditional?
G: I would start this challenge again with Hannah and Mamrie to make it a tradition for us
H: I love that. I love it
H: That sounds great
G: But we're gonna are switching things up. Last time we just tried not to laugh. This time around
G: We're doing three different rounds. First round, I will play a part from this
G: From this fart sound board challenge
G: You can find on internet because the internet is great and these two will write down what they think the title of that fart is
G Because there are amazing titles. This is my job.
M: How does my mom explain this to people??
G: And then round two they will hear a fart, they'll have to tell me who made that fart
M: Well, I think that round should just be called 'Who Fahted?'
G: And the third round we'll go back to the old tradition, and you guys will try not to laugh
M: Okay perfect
G: So round one you guys have to tell me the name of this fart, so you've white boards to write them down
G: Oh my God, here we go. Ready?
M: Oh my God, I'm so nervous
G: I'll play it again for those in the back
H: I'm ready
M: I'm ready too
G: Okay, um
G: Hannah, let's see what you think the name of that fart is
H: I think that fart is called Cello!
H: I'm back. It's got lower tones. And then it's like exciting up top, but then it's like hey
All: Cello! I'm back.
G: K, Mamrie, what do you think?
M: Uh, I named it Guy Fieri's Queef Bucket
H: Ahh, sweet Jesus
G: The actual name of this fart is called Rectal Bismol
G: Rectal Bismol!
H: Can I just say for the record
G: That this is your favorite challenge?
H: Oh my god,  I just don't get it
M: I love it
G: You don't know why farts people laugh?
H: No!
M: They're the silliest sounds!
G: Okay here's our next fart!
G: One more time!
M: [laughing] Three for the price of one!
H: Alright, I got mine
G: Okay. Mamrie is almost done
G: Mamrie's writing a chapter of her book
G: Hannah, what is the name of fart number two?
H: I called it Tiny Toots
M: [singing] Tiny Toots!
H: Butt art
M: Aww, it's a butt! That's good. I named it Manicotti Hottie
M: Full title: 'that's a spicy heat ball'
G: The actual name of this fart is 'Nice Try!"
H: Noo! Ooh!
H: Wait... Ohh!
G: Nice Try!
H: Were they trying to fart more or less? That's a real question
M: Did they try to hold it in?
G: They tried to pretend they weren't gonna fart!
M: Nice Try!
G: This is the last one of this round. Score is, no surprise, zero to zero
H: Okay... One more time?
G: [plays the fart]
H: Okay, I'm ready
G: Hannah, what's yours?
H: I called it Bloomberg
G & M: Ohhh
M: Political
H: Right? Sounds like- could you play it?
G: [plays fart]
M: Yeahh, Bloomberg!
H: It's a serious fart!
G: Okay, Mamrie, what'd you call it?
M: Uh, She's All Splat
G: Close! This one is called 'George Push'
Yeah, listen to it. Oh
Hey, I don't get a point for that. [I] mean oh, no oh 0 to [0] oh yeah this [game] this man
You was on me for it. This is based off your opinion
Yeah
This is basically what I think is the correct opinion of celebrity or just pedestrian it does matter battery or whatever comes to mind
God, I'm and this one. I get to tell you the names of the parts, okay this one is perfect this one's called touche
Touche oh my God way one more time. Oh
God, that's a sassy fart okay. I'm ready when you guys are okay, Mamrie
What do you fall on it a french waiter on the smoke break?
Music he's get it all out. He's like [even] he's got a whole section
He's Gonna
Have a cig and he's like I gotta get all my farts out
Because I can't be dropping the caca Vaughn small fart and feels fake I meanshe
[sushi] [Shack] kind of who fought it um Robert Durst the band of the James
like
It's like nothing you can do
[Mm-Hmm], so he's like uh I
Love it. Yeah, I think [one] ought to give it to handle [ah]
next
Fart in this round who fought it. Well fought it. Well boss called air biscuit. I feel air biscuit. [well]
it's in the first gun hitting so - ah
Okay, memory who bought it. Okay. You read up here that Amber's good again [ah]
I said it's a nun on a roller [coaster] when it goes upside down
I
Don't know who bought it. Okay. I said someone when they went to pee and a crowded public restroom a woman
And they like go to pee and they're like a camp piano something oh
Yeah, trying to suck out at it. I'm gonna have to give it to memory ah
Another visual okay the third part in the round who fought it. It's called anus Madness no cheese
penis
anus Madness
Guys this kept going they got it going. I don't even know how to get it to stop
[the] loominator fart. Oh, okay it's over. So who farted?
I would play it again, but I definitely don't want to and now guys okay
Maimre okay? Well you did Robert durst. I'm going for fred durst and a macaroni girl bathroom while getting a blowjob from
Grafite tricks like he's farting the whole time. [oh]
my God Anna
[breaded] the first Caveman who ever farted and wanted to show all the other cavemen. I love it. That's so cute
I was [pro] magnum just for clarification what era we were thinking [oh]
I'm gonna have to give it to me me I feel [yeah]
Submit [it's] again visual visual fred Durst is just you know yes. No boundaries
You got limp biskit you got Erebus I?
Remember bond [it] to round 3 the final round where it's just a matter of trying not to laugh
[I] say I'm going into this round pretty comfy. I know you are
I'm not so you can't laugh at the name, okay first one is called would you like ketchup?
Would you like ketchup chat and let's hear would you let ketchup?
After anus madness I feel like all of [me] [is] so tape. I know they're all [seemed] so small, okay
We'll just do three okay. I mean not one went to hannah very clearly let's go
Monica you is stinky
You is stinky listen
Monica pretty nice [form] is pretty tame [came] part came [far] the last one okay the fart first
And then I'll tell you the name out okay at it. Okay. Give me strength [pin], so we go
Okay, got through it. The name is faeces pieces
mean
I think one we all I mean everyone's a winner
Especially the creator of the ultimate farts on board wherever you are wherever you are. Thank you
Thank you, and like [others] might be in a future. We might need a writer. Yeah
I mean our next movie should be called Monica
Why he's chosen you
Guys want more giggles like that go over and check out these two dummies
channels because we shot videos over there all in honor of dirty 30 and don't bring it again to preorder dirty 30 on iTunes or
On dirty 30 movie calm. We should make a fart call the dirty [throwing] dirt. Oh yet. There's already 30
30 30 dirty picture so many [or] so many [could] say so much with them in your part these is no [my] movie. Oh
I'm not gonna. I'm not gonna. Ask you to play name is Madness again. [no]. I didn't know the anus Madness was truly mad
Yes, and do savage Garden's song